- If you thought the "Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills"
was crazy, wait till you see the
"Real Lawyers of the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills."
As you may know, Erika
Girardi, one of the stars
of the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills,
was married to a
once-legendary trial attorney
named Tom Girardi.
Tom Girardi created the
well-known plaintiffs' firm
Girardi Keese.
But that firm is in bankruptcy,
in part because of all of the allegations
of impropriety by Tom Girardi.
Among those include a
potentially $20 million
that Girardi gave to his then-wife Erika.
Erika Girardi filed for divorce
in November of last year.
Erika Girardi's attorney
has tried to withdraw
from representing her,
but now has backed away
and is now representing her again.
And a federal judge froze
all Tom Girardi's assets
because there was evidence
that he stole $2 million
from spouses and orphans of a plane crash
that he was representing.
Yes, truth is sometimes
crazier than fiction,
but one thing is for sure, we
will see all of them in court.